Je suis parti pour le Nord il y a environ 12 mois
et c'est la première des
découvertes que j'ai faites une myriade de mondes
dont le Magistère ne contrôle qu'un seul
depuis des siècles ils essaient de
nous maintenir là où ils veulent nous mettre à genoux
tu as promis le  Le contrôle du rendement du Magistère
est réel, ils devront
prendre les choses en main
Lara, un grand changement arrive qui
nous menacera tous. Je vais
vous donner quelque chose, qu'est-ce que c'est - il a un rôle
à jouer dans tout cela et un  le major, dis-
moi où se trouve Alethea mati, nous
représentons un certain nombre de familles qui ont
perdu des enfants, c'est la guerre,
je pense que les nouvelles peuvent aider,
elle peut lire le compteur de Lethe, elle
nous sera plus précieuse que n'importe quel soldat que
nous avons pour récupérer nos enfants.  vous avez
peut-être du cœur mais le Magistère a
des muscles, de quoi d'autre avons-nous besoin pour
les combattre c'est un bon ours vous n'aurez aucun
problème
les sorcières connaissent les autres mondes
depuis des milliers d'années
Azrael apporte une grande guerre alors j'espère que
je le ferai  forte, n'a pas vraiment besoin de mourir,
c'est le moment de choisir son camp, il y
a des choses si importantes
pour elle, qu'est-ce que
le monde voit les possibilités,
plus d'oppression, malheureux, il y a plus
d'abus, plus d'obscurité, le sort de plus
que ce monde dépend d'elle.